c'est de plus en plus en vogue et on en
parle beaucoup acheté une voiture
électrique entièrement électrique y en a
plusieurs qui se pose la question est ce
que ça vaut le coup un des questions
d'autonomie elle reste il reste les mots
cela marche de protégez-vous c'est
pencher là dessus avec toute votre
équipe bonjour alors dites moi qu'est ce
qu'on retrouve déjà en page couverture
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve dans votre
numéro là dessus il ya beaucoup de
choses d'abord dans les derniers mois
ont évalué environ 25 véhicules
électriques donc que dans ce numéro si
on vous présente une sélection de six
modèles qui nous paraissait les plus
intéressants on a aussi fait un test en
laboratoire en collaboration avec que
transition énergétique québec de borda
installé à la maison donc bornes de
recharge huit bornes concertiste qui
était vraiment les mettre dans des
conditions climatiques difficiles voire
six si elle réussit à bien faire et on a
aussi bon toutes sortes de témoignages
une liste d'incitatifs financiers
davantage des comparatifs de prix donc
vraiment pour faire le tour de la
question pour quelqu'un qui songerait
acheter avec les yeux du moment c'est la
question à 63 mille dollars
les consoles que vous on peut d'abord on
les véhicules électriques sont encore
plus chers que leurs équivalents essence
par contre lorsqu'on prend en
considération le faible coût de
l'énergie
les différentes subventions les coûts
d'entretien ainsi que son coût moindre
pour un véhicule électrique pour un
véhicule à essence ça commence à devenir
très intéressant le d'opter pour un
véhicule électrique
les d'ailleurs on voit que les ventes
augmentent et que c'est pour quelqu'un
qui songe à faire le saut c'est
peut-être vraiment le bon moment
l'autonomie aussi des véhicules a
augmenté beaucoup ces dernières années
donc sur ce système pour info il ya
quand même quelques freins d'abord il
n'y a pas énormément de moder encore sur
le marché les constructeurs on n'arrive
pas à suivre la cadence de la demande du
marché
puis aussi pratiquement aucun véhicule
usagers de sur le marché des véhicules
d'occasion ou en fait et vécu qu'on
retrouve sont beaucoup moins intéressant
parce que les technologies changent
tellement rapidement joué ceux qui
disent on lisait malheurs sont pas
porter des valeurs qui sont les modèles
de cayenne qui retiennent l'attention
si on regarde côté du tout électrique on
a d'abord la nissan leaf un véhicule qui
se vend environ 40000 dollars qui à 250
km d'autonomie l'été donc un bon rapport
qualité prix
un petit bémol c'est l'assistant la
conduite qui était pas tout à fait au
niveau d'autres véhicules
sinon on a aussi un petit but est donc
l'un des co na électrique l'on parle
d'un véhicule de plus tôt 50000 dollars
mais qu'une auto mines une autonomie de
400 km l'été donc là ça commence à être
plus intéressant la question autonomie
bonne tenue de route
si j'avais à dire un bémol ce serait le
beau me le bruit devant la haute vitesse
qui on peut déranger le dos bon je vous
avais dit allez vous avez dit l'été à
deux reprises en faisant quelques ya une
grosse différence c'est sûr ça va
dépendre de comment vous utilisez votre
chauffage aussi mais la batterie est
plus sollicité l'hiver ce qui fait que
quand même et vous avez vous avez
également regarder les hybrides les
écouter le chargeur on à la chevrolet
volt qui est un véhicule qui se vend
environ 1 45 mille dollars 85 km
d'autonomie avant de
d'avoir recours au moteur à essence donc
encore une fois bonne tenue de route
goût des espaces dans le coffre aussi
sinon modèles moins chers la prius prime
à 35000 dollars
par contre avec la prius vous n'aurez
pas droit au maximum des subventions le
des gouvernements comparé aux autres que
le don josé paris est aussi vous aurez
seulement 35 km d'autonomie avant
d'avoir recours au moteur à essence donc
si vous travaillez assez proche de votre
lieu de résidence vous faites peu de
kilométrage ça peut être quand même un
véhicule intéressant vient vous voir
partir de bord de disponibilité de bon
je vois un très très grand fabricant qui
commence par la lettre t qui souvent est
présenté mais est-ce que ça devient de
plus en plus facile de trouver des bons
publics y en a qui s'ajoute le on y crie
mais l'article pillon et ajustées il y
en a vraiment de plus en plus par contre
comme plusieurs réseaux qui fonctionnent
en parallèle qui ont pas tout exactement
les mêmes façons de fois faut être
membre des foires les coûts sont pas
pareils des fois faut mettre de l'argent
sur une carte tesla fait complètement
cavalier seul avec son propre réseau
sont assez propre adaptateur qui sont
pas nécessairement compatibles
donc on voit que c'est un marché encore
qui peut tout à fait mature donc il ya
encore beaucoup de mouvements mais c'est
certain que des bandes qui s'ajoutent
aussi des applications pour pouvoir les
trouver facilement le sueur sur votre si
vous avez un parcours un chemin à faire
beau ou est-ce que je vais arrêter pour
charger donc il ya des applications mais
bon je pense qu'on a vraiment beaucoup
de changement de ce côté là les proches
comme ça serait bon du fort bien sûr
c'est un peu comme les délicats cette
bêta faudra une fois merci beaucoup
d'être à nouveau retrouvé travailler
comme ça